Commonly, this tidying focuses on cleaning up
individual columns and rows based on specific logic.
Let's start with the columns.
I'll show you how this works in practice in a moment,
but big picture,
you can remove columns or remove other columns.
You can do this by either removing a specific individual column or you can
select the columns you want to keep and remove the other columns around them.
This can come in handy when you load a very large table with dozens of columns,
but you only need three.
You can rename columns to something more user-friendly,
think back to that report or you can reorder
your columns to whatever the preferred order is for you for ease of use.
Note that there are many more column transformations beyond this,
which we'll get into during the next lesson.
One common source of concern newer Power BI users share
when they're transforming data in Power BI for the very first time,
is that they're afraid that they might delete something by
mistake by removing it in Power Query.
If there's one thing you take away from this lesson,
please let it be that you cannot damage the underlying data
by manipulating or even breaking the query in Power Query.
What you see in the Power Query window is a reflection of the data from the source,
not the source data itself.
If you find that you need to adjust a transformation that you made earlier on,
it's actually quite easy to make those corrections,
something we'll talk about later in this lesson.
Let's take a quick look at sales data for a corporate report.
The columns that you choose to remove or
keep will really depend on the use case that you have.
If you're working on a data set for a corporate report and have
a number of customer columns available from the sales team,
you might really just want to keep a few and remove the rest.
In comparison, if you are creating a data model,
focus on the sales team's needs.
You might keep most of those columns and just remove the one.